tucked between the alps at the border of
italy and switzerland is a restaurant
for tourists visiting from around the
world the refugio guide del chervino
offers a break from winter sports for
food drinks lodging and as this reviewer
called it a great italian experience
but something unexpected is happening
here the nearby theodol glacier is
melting and as it does this little
italian ski lodge is on the verge of
moving
into switzerland
most of italy's land border follows the
watershed along the alps there is this
imaginary line that divides the water
that fell into the mediterranean sea in
the south or in the north they go on the
black sea by the danube or in the north
sea that's marco ferrari he wrote a book
about this border with architect andrea
banyato and visual designer elisa
pasqual
this watershed line traces many of the
highest peaks of the alps forming a
natural border between countries much of
it is marked by over 8 000 boundary
stones like these some of which have
been around since the 16th century
but in the most rugged terrain where
physical markers are few and far between
swiss italian and austrian cartographic
agencies have long maintained official
border records with meticulous
measurements and annotated pictures like
these
some of these areas are on top of
glaciers their surfaces are too
reflective for satellites which are
often used to measure borders the work
by the surveyors is done manually so
every few years
there is a commission of surveyors the
composer members of both countries that
actually walk the border
and look how it's changed as early as
the 1920s surveyors noticed a slow but
progressive shrinking among glaciers and
that some had disappeared but by the
1990s it became clear that summer melt
had outpaced winter accumulation the
surveyors realized that the glacier were
melting and not humiliating ice anymore
this kind of cyclical change
in the shape and geometry of the
watershed became more and more permanent
and as glaciers shifted so did the
watershed and so did the border here's
what that looks like
on many alpine peaks a glacier ridge
forms the watershed boundary line and
thus the national border
but as those glaciers melt their highest
point might shift often dozens of meters
away if they melt far enough they even
reveal underlying rock peaks which then
become the borderline
these black x's mark the old national
boundary between italy and switzerland
but if you trace today's national
boundary and compare it to old maps you
can see all the places where the
boundary line has moved
in the most extreme case yet in the alps
ships in the theater glacier moved the
border 150 meters
that put this italian ski lift on swiss
soil
and the refugio guide del chervino might
be next
typically when countries renegotiate
borders there's a careful process to
make sure that neither country gains
territory at the other's expense but
recently italy signed a new type of
agreement first with austria in 2006 and
then with switzerland in 2009 that
recognized the alps as a mobile border
acknowledging that the border was
subject to changes in the natural world
outside of those countries control
fortunately the refugio is the only
inhabited place along this shifting
border and if it becomes swiss it'll be
subject to swiss law taxes and customs
they might have to change their wall
plugs but for most nearby residents the
changes won't mean much but if we think
about different areas of the world where
similar processes are happening for
example the malaya
or the understand these are completely
different political situations
in which also the scale of the
phenomenon is much much bigger
the histories are much more conflicted
in the himalayas china and india
disagree about their border and have
fought over it several times as it
continues to melt and shift and in the
andes chile and argentina have long
disagreed about their own melting border
as climate change warms the planet and
moves water-based borders these
conflicts could worsen
rivers which make up over a third of the
length of all international land
boundaries will be subject to extreme
events that can change their course
coastlines will give way to rising seas
affecting exclusive economic zones where
a country's sovereignty extends into the
ocean and glaciers like in the alps will
continue to melt the alpine mobile
border is almost like a laboratory a
prototype
of a condition that will happen more and
more in a lot of different parts of the
world
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's take the paper out